nostalgia critic cannot be here right
now due to recent some vengeance but he
has letter recording before he left for
you to enjoy
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to to err
is human today the worst piece of
half-assed County shit to ever start bad
acting seven foot basketball superstar
it's unforgivable sorry sorry it's just
why was this one bad I mean you have no
idea if this movie was a dog I'd haven't
put down if this movie was a car I'd
have it impounded if this movie was a
starving young woman who pleaded to me
for just a bite of my Hamlin salami
sandwich I would kill her all right
that's a little dark but you get what
I'm getting it that's a kind of hatred
this movie has driven me to if you
haven't guessed yet I'm of course
talking about the whimsical and magical
journey that is Kazan it's uninvented
unimaginative and unbelievably retarded
but hey don't take my word for it let's
take a look the movie stars Shaquille
O'Neal sit back down
apparently back in the 90s people
thought if you could look in the camera
and say drink pepsi you are considered a
good actor that's an insult
so touchstone made a deal with Shaquille
O'Neal to starting the latest
family-friendly romp in the movies you
kill plays and I'm quoting here a rapid
genie with attitude who's ready for a
slam dunk fun they need to say is that
it's a corporate ride off to make a
quick buck to entertain my lips porta W
kids who think that just because a man
can make a decent three-throw means you
can make a decent crackdown movie like
this one but I digress what's the movie
about
well it opens up with a wrecking ball no
doubt with metaphors and respite a film
and that's over a lamp that apparently
holds the genie
which forces him to fall into a boom box
which I guess the genie decides to call
his new home
Cheney the boombox could possibly be a
musical romp let's see what they'll miss
though cruel all right so we need a boy
named Max who apparently likes to walk
around school and make faces at this
mentally retarded kid he's caught by
some bullies who spray-paint him to the
ground and chase him all throughout the
city of new Bronx lick I love a scene
here where he tries to escape the boys
to her fast he went through a hole what
do we do he went through a hole
what do we do what do we do with Rojo
what do we do with the hole what were
you oh yeah go through the holes
seriously a blind on me vodka figure
that out
so they chase him into that abandoned
building though being torn down but stop
being torn down for some reason where he
finds the boom box and accidentally
unleashes the genie
where in the fable doesn't say genies
spin like Tasmanian Devils down to wake
me ain't gonna make this the mystery
that sorry wanna be that the syrup I see
really this is that quote unquote
rapping genie they were talking about um
I feel let you guys know that there is a
huge difference between rapping and
rhyming rapping is this Rock rules that
make moves with all the mommies to the
back of the Pacific moment that's what
you come on rhyming is this I saw a dog
got a lot of lock this movie is fun you
see it's very very different if you got
the itches for second richest don't
matter how apparitions of the man Becca
grant your wishes brittish's so Kazan
tells max that he's his G but max
doesn't believe him imagine that so
Kazan tries to show off his powers and
Wow my wish actually came true take to
zoo right here dum-dums so max goes home
and finds that his mother is getting
engaged to a fireman who looks like
Steve Guttenberg's even less talented
brother listen max I don't intend to
take the place of your father I just
wanna be the guy who helps your mother
he also finds out that his mother lied
to him about real father's whereabouts
and turns out she's actually located in
the city so max decides to set out and
look for him hoping to rekindle some
sort of sacred family bond I guess they
just abandoned the whole Genie thing it
looks like they're gonna focus on the
importance of unity and finding your
family we're off up areas like really
lonely or something so cuz they have
pesters max until he decides to believe
him and make a wish with a shit-eating
grin so say look he gives when he's
advertising something don't you wish you
had one of these actually if I'm the
only one who's freaked out by this a
tall bearded man with the evil grin is
following a little boy around offering
him treats and saying he can make all
his wishes come true this is a family
film right get your fat ass back here so
max finally finds his real father only
to discover he's a musical talent agent
working in the underground world of
pirated music that bashfully slimeball
who's that loser how's my father I guess
I have an emotion here but I don't want
to so max goes to a secret hideout which
is filled with all the stuff TGI Fridays
didn't want and finds you know who
they're here max talks about father and
I guess shag just great some more is
that a wish
rather than decide to move forward with
the plot they decide to have a pointless
bike ride here the genie finally shows
off his real powers don't drill
say thank you for your miracle what's
the matter
your tongue is broken time like this you
should be spoken you want this film to
be good and I'm not joking grab yourself
a J and get to smoke it no truer words
have ever been spoken it'll see you much
better once you've been token see I can
do it too it's not hard oh my gosh it's
got a dick Isaiah just go back to the
future he comes back looking like a
Cadbury egg dressed as Liberace and
finally convinces max to make his first
wish button ride of course I wish I junk
food from here to stop why not
higher than I that's the understatement
so Scheck is the almighty genie
literally makes junk food fall from the
sky but only the stuff is promoted from
pants commercials
so while munching on his munchies Max
comes to a sudden realization until I
make those last two wishes
I own you don't care my list so a white
person owns a black person to provide
services against his will without
getting paid there's a word for
advantage I think what it is
um ownership no no not that that's not
it that's not it
um possession no no that's not what I'm
looking for either it's it's something
long lines of um um what is wrong with
this movie that's horrible
so max in his well I guess there's no
other word for it slave go looking
around the neighborhood to see if they
can find his father at some point his
pants fall I don't know why I guess it's
supposed to be funny ha and they end up
at his father's place again
here they come across an intimidating
bodyguard
this isn't a toy store unless you want
to play
my game of course what they don't show
you in the scene is his face right
afterwards so max finally locates his
father once again and as suspected he's
a douche let this get in here which was
an amusement park amusement park but
once his dad finds out that he literally
produced him he changes his tone of it
everybody quiet down boy down check this
out this is my boy max whoa hey about
that but that be dead so the father
invites bags to his hot sexy nightclub
because that's a perfect place for a
ten-year-old where kazoom starts to dig
those groovy funky beats oh the cue do
the babe from another planet
don't just stare come over here and let
me see you GD GD damn it don't encourage
him yo jiggy jiggy regret it what if
they don't like you're ready to like to
question it
please do sit down and hung quietly get
set for my tentative check cuz I have to
say
looking at your dream and your coffee
down between oh come on vanilla ice was
blacker than ss3 they can have it what
that's three they can happen where's the
Seuss gosh
don't get me that's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard in my life there's
something an infant says why he's just
learning how to read never in my life
have I ever seen something so stupid
meanwhile we come across a guy who has
thick eyebrows so obviously he must be
the villain he's interested in the magic
gold flashy stuff that comes out of
Shaq's boom box he quickly realizes that
he's a genie and tries to use Max's
father as a way of controlling him
meanwhile Max is back home sleeping 100
bad touch not one emergency there's a
tall man who's been stalking this kid
giving him treats and now he's touching
emilynics been wearing this pajamas all
right yummy buzzer that's right kid
fight him fight him ah smelly cat hurry
so after that bit if I don't want to
know what Kazan comes out and introduces
himself as Max's news tutor because he
really looks like your traditional
egghead doesn't he
he then indulges and yet another
pointless scene where he makes french
toast fly
that's sad when the breakfast is the
best actor in the movie yeah he then
goes outside to talk to Kazaam about how
him does bother are not really
connecting looks like the worst thing
you've ever seen in your life
audience this movie but rather than talk
about their problems cuz he decides he
wants to do something better rap about
them I didn't have this friend in 2000
BC listen to my rap bell to bell don't
you know these guys um I was thinking
rather than succumbing to what's popular
norm I was on thinking maybe could have
a um a real conversation uh you know and
nothing too deep but I'm just saying
that you know this is a possibility
maybe there's a deep personal pain that
you don't want to acknowledge that maybe
now talk write change big things
different talking about shin gym what's
here Jin is free Jing could do anything
problem is generally exist in fairy
tales
I don't believe in fairy tales wait what
generally exist in fairy tales I don't
believe in fairy tales
the genie doesn't believe in fairy tales
something's wrong
that's just
Blake Maxine since father get beat up by
senior thick brows and calls on Kazan
for his help
coz mi gotta make a wish what are you
doing get off the table
Sam I need a wish okay right now no
intrusion fifty you stupid entity cut
out what the hell is up with that glass
of water thing what use a glass of water
he's only bogeys on the table I knew
what why did that happen
is it like Super Mario Brothers is it a
warp zone you know what forget it
fine let's just move on the move your be
over faster that way so anyway rather
than help max with his problem cuz n got
a recording deal as a professional
rapper I'm dead serious
I guess his hit single like in jam with
Sam I am went straight to the top
meanwhile the bastard son of Mario and
Saddam Hussein kidnaps the kid takes
possession of his boom box that gets the
kid the shaft and summons Kazan to his
warehouse where he demands him to do all
his evil bidding
Kazaam is powerless to stop his new
master wait a minute
way to go Sam find it you can do it
cousin
you can break free for the white man's
chains
he's gonna go Shaq throw on your asses
and in typical basketball all-star
fashion he personally slam dunks the
villain into a garbage
but unfortunately it's too late
little mags it appears is dead there's
nothing to do now the Motta's
emotionally lacking moment with totally
inappropriate music
you're the only friend I've ever had
when you needed me the most I wasn't
there
yeah you were a bit of a douche cos I
just wish I could have granted your wish
I wished I could have filled your heart
well life's a bitch and I'm little kids
died of course he doesn't die because
Kazan realizes the value of human life
or something like that he is free from
his bonds unable to breathe life back
into little max
you're alive kid so Shaq brings max back
to life turns into this thing and
reunites him back with his father on top
of that he also becomes human which
means you can it down for Jon
a job he can't get a job he's a genie ha
ha it's pretty out there
ha ha my hairy ass
this movie is wretched a festering Shack
of shit if I had just one wish one wish
it would be that this movie never
existed and that's why I have no doubt
that Citizen Kane is one of the worst
films of all time
under the stylish Critic I remember so
you don't have to swipe it God is Jesus
right thank you dr. Seuss cuz I am
organized you are looking at your dream
you like popsicles